I want to welcome everyone to the 11th
annual Yale any a BPD conference we're
so pleased to have everyone here today
including and especially our speakers we
have a really wonderful lineup and we
hope that you really enjoyed and get a
lot out of it first I want to just thank
the providers of this conference because
this conference is entirely both a
volunteer and sponsor effort first and
foremost we have any a BPD um who has
really contributed and developed this
conference for the last 11 years we also
want to yes yeah actually let's get
let's give a round of applause there I
also want to thank heel New Haven
Hospital for their efforts to help us
continue this conference for 11 years
and the Yale stress center yes purchase
house here in the Yale School of
Medicine Department of Psychiatry where
this conference is based thank you very
much to all of our providers I also want
to thank as I mentioned this is an
entirely volunteer effort and as you can
see on the screen it takes numerous
people to get this together every single
year we have conference coordinators
Susannah Decker Rachel litwin Francesca
paraplegic ova who's going to be one of
our speakers today Liz Rapoza Jackie
Smith and Trish Woodward who have all
contributed significant effort we also
have a number of conference staff and
numerous conference volunteers who you
will see in the hallways and at the
registration desk today if you can just
join me in a for a moment in thanking
all of these people for all the hours
that they have dedicated so that we can
have this today
I'm so first off I want to introduce
Perry Hoffman she's the president and
co-founder of the national education
alliance for BPD she's also a
co-director of the conference so please
join me in welcoming dr. Hoffman well
welcome and thank you Emily and I think
we need to give you a round of applause
because of all the hard work that you
have done so thank you for doing this
and thanks to Seth out of Axelrod those
of you who've been at this conference
before know my story with Seth who
stalked me to make sure we did this
conference so 11 years in the making and
it has set the model for other
universities to want to have annual
conferences as well so we're delighted
again to be to be here well today is May
first which kicks-off BPD awareness
month this is our poster that
acknowledges the disorder and the need
for awareness we hope that you'll help
spread the word and if you go on our
website which is borderline personality
disorder calm you can download this
poster and share it with people put it
up in your office or do whatever you
want with it but we have 31 days now of
promoting especially the awareness on
this disorder so today I'm not going to
spend much time talking because what I'd
like to do is introduce to you what what
is our hallmark program called family
connections and i'm inviting matt and an
Costello who are our leaders who've
probably run the most groups of anybody
they're probably up to about 15 groups
now so I would like to ask them to come
up and talk to you a little bit about
our that program and hopefully be able
to get some people on that resource
that's so needed thank you
thanks Perry I'm where Matney and
Costello from Westchester down in
Katonah New York and we do family
connections at new york-presbyterian
hospital all year long basically we had
a tough winter this winter we had to
cancel lots of snow days math is going
to tell you a little bit about what we
do and we do it because we love it we
have two children who have online
personality disorder so I assume a lot
of people here probably know about
family connections it's a 12 session
could be 12 week so you don't get snow
days course it's manualized it is based
on DBT developed by dr. Alan frazzetti
dr. Perry Hoffman by parents and
consumers and family members and what it
does is it teaches family skills to deal
with what they're dealing with when as
we're kind of into fact lickable is that
the word attica because when you see
what this program can do when people
arrive basically broken on the rocks of
what they've been dealing with and 12
weeks later they're hugging each other
they're laughing and many cases things
have not changed but they have changed
dramatically because they have learned
skills to deal with their life so when
we just finished our last class last
Sunday and someone wrote on the card
they gave us as she said you have given
joy back to my life because joy had gone
away so I mean that gives me goosebumps
so how could you not do that anyway that
that's the program it's a very really
something that if you don't know about
it's done both in a face-to-face version
we do it in the hospital because every
time we do it 20 23 people show up but
also a telephone version where you can
be in omaha you can be an anchorage if
you want to be wherever you'd like to be
you could be doing the course and even
around the world if you'd like more
information we have a table up there we
have a flyer on people can sign up you
can register you can certainly speak to
us we'll be around all day to ask us
about it
and that's the program yeah it's a free
program by the way over it it's free and
parents just can't believe that they got
more out of a free program than they did
from the thousands of dollars they pay
thank you